merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Premier Ministre ma question porte sur
l'assurance des collectivités vous le
savez nos collectivités sont confrontées
à des difficultés pour s'assurer et la
situation en ce 2024 est très
préoccupante s'il y a quelques mois ces
difficultés portaient davantage sur
l'assurance statutaire et RH et sur les
villes petites et moyennes dans
certaines zones très exposées tous les
risques toutes les strates de
collectivité et tout le territoire
national sont aujourd'hui concernés 2000
d'entre elles seraient sans couverture
dans mon département la vois une enquête
montre que 33 % des communes interrogées
sont confrontés à la résiliation
unilatérale de leur contrat à
l'augmentation des primes ou des
franchistes de 25 jusqu'à 100 % en
particulier sur les dommages au bi la
responsabilité civile et les flottes
automobiles nos collectivités sont donc
conduite à s'auto-assurer avec des
risques financiers énormes cette
situation s'explique par un marché de
l'assurance qui est déficitaire une
sinistralité conjoncturelle de plus en
plus importante en témoigne les 200
millions d'euros de dégâts qui ont été
constatés sur les émeutes de cet été
mais surtout par une sinistralité
climatique qui explose elle a triplé
entre 2018 et 2022 par rapport à la
période précédente le coût des dégâts
des catastrophes naturelles pourrait
atteindre 3 milliards d'euros par an
d'ici 2050 pour autant l'État n'est pas
resté Sour et a annoncé des mesures une
mission gouvernementale sur
l'assurabilité des collectivités
conduite par Alain chrétien et jean-
dagess a été nommée ces conclusions sont
attendu pour fin avril et nous
conduirons certainement à un travail
législatif mais dans l'intervalle le
nombre de collectivités impacté ne cesse
de s'accroître et les catastrophes
naturelles se multiplient j'aurais une
pensée pour nos compatriotes du
pastecalais et de la Réunion et pour
leurs élus locaux qui sont en première
ligne dans la gestion de l'après au
moment où les discussions budgétaires
sont en cours dans nos communes comment
l'État compte-ils travailler ce sujet
avec les représentants des associations
d'élus comment envisagez-vous le soutien
aux collectivités qui se trouvve sans
couverture assurancielle nos élus
partout ont besoin d'être rassuré et
soutenus je vous
remercie